come on
[Applause]
this target practice
body camera video shows what led up to a
deadly shooting in Atlanta when
officials opened fire at a public safety
training site
that's it
hey watch Crossfire guys
it happened on January 18th when Atlanta
police officers were working to clear
the land that will house a future Public
Safety Training Center at the time
activists were camping at the site to
protest Construction in the forest
tents are going to be unoccupied
as you can go
gasoline anything that could be used to
hurt
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
it's like a blow torch
after nine o'clock in the morning shots
rang out
all our machines on this side okay we've
got to leave somebody to guard those
machines okay there's a tent right up
here
[Applause]
is this target practice
the video shows officers calling for
everyone to turn on their body cameras
[Music]
officers then make their way toward a
tent as they're instructed to stay alert
clear that's it
foreign
stay online stay online
outright
hey watch Crossfire guys
at this point officers are still
wondering whether it was actually shots
fired or just a firework
all right
before somebody shooting
into firework or some
where
like five rapping uh
it soon becomes clear that shots were
fired
come
on
there we go
63. all right all units
with the officer who is injured
what agency is that
copy is the officer can you give us a
status
I knew it was gunshots they said they
said uh
fireworks
that was they would turn it up
officers later learned that the shooting
happened between Georgia State Patrol
Troopers and 26 year old activists
Manuel Esteban Paez Tehran who was
inside a tent Georgia State Patrol
doesn't wear body cams except in
specific situations and in this incident
troopers were not wearing cameras all
the body camera video comes from the
Atlanta Police Department
thank you
officials say at least one bullet was
fired by Tehran with a nine millimeter
gun he legally purchased the bullet hit
a trooper in the pelvic area he was
wearing a bulletproof vest at the time
after the shooting officers worked to
bring the trooper to safety while
securing tehran's tent
let's go get close Arch
ER
negative
okay you got eyes on this side in an
effort to get Tehran out of the tent
Atlanta PD Officers opt to use a less
lethal agent by firing pepper balls in
his direction we got less lethal I do
have Leslie do you want to shoot a few
yeah right come up here
announce first announce first
Glenna police
we have a lead we have a non-lethal
agent will be administered into the tent
if you don't come out with your hands up
again this is Atlanta Police Department
with les lethal agent that will be
administered into the tent if you do not
come out with your hands up
please
thank you
nine rounds
you got Council
officers can be heard on body camera
video saying there should be coughing
coming from the tent I don't hear any
coughing you'd be coughing right now
um one research did I really got yeah
what'd you shoot in there no we don't
need the dog it's yeah pepperball agent
we'll go up there
from personal experience you you hear
coughing up there right now body camera
video captures officers coughing as they
approach the tent
wow
good job
officers later found Tehran dead outside
of his tent a spokesperson for his
family says a private autopsy found he
was shot 13 times reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie